[Music]
hi I'm Greg Sadler that YouTube
philosophy guy what I want to start
doing is taking the videos that I've
been creating over the last seven years
and converting them into mp3s that I can
release as a podcast for listeners
worldwide I've pledged to start doing
that once I reach a sufficient level of
support on patreon so I'm asking you to
become one of my patreon supporters
viewers subscribers fans of all sorts
have been asking me to do this now for
quite some time and I always balked at
it because it's such a big job I've got
over 1,300 videos at present and I
produced another 250 on average per year
some of them are over an hour long so
this is going to be a lot of work it's a
big project but I'm I'm up for doing it
if people will help support me in
creating these these many many podcast
episodes that then you can listen to
anywhere you go the key factor for me is
that of time I have to carve out the
time to take all of these videos and
then convert them into mp3s and all the
data you know all the sort of things
that go into podcasting and that means
that it ties in with one of my key goals
which is doing the work that I love and
bringing philosophy is all of you who
benefit from it and appreciate it and at
the same time
earning a sufficient income for myself
and my family so there's a trade-off
between time and money or resources and
that's why I'm talking to you about
patreon here I should mention as well
that I conceived of this as baby steps
into doing original podcasting which
I've pledged to do once I reach a higher
level of patreon support because of
course that takes a lot of time
thought and energy as well so if you
like you can contribute you can also
share this video widely if you commit
even just the amount that you spend on a
candy bar once a month you make a huge
difference as crowdfunding adds up if
you want to contribute more there's a
lot of cool perks that everybody gets
access to even at the lowest level but
then going on up so go to the website
check it out think about supporting me
and again share this with anybody who
you think might be interested in seeing
high quality philosophy podcasting out
there in the ether for those of you who
are sharing this or who have decided to
contribute let me say thank you up front
and let me give a big capital T thank
you to all of my current patreon
supporters who got me to this point
where I can actually start thinking
about doing this really cool project so
thanks once again and consider backing
this project
[Music]
you